police held and Republican candidate for
governor of New York joins us now
all right
Congressman
um
we see this strategy here Hillary used
it yesterday and hokel's using it now
that crime and the threat of crime is a
tactic being used by you and others it's
an exaggeration it's a perception
problem more than a reality problem okay
so here's the best part of that clip you
just showed is that she's saying that
right next to them showing all the
different major crime categories that
are way up year over year so she she
says it's data denial to be saying that
we have a crime issue she says it's a
conspiracy and even CNN this morning
when she's doing that side by side it's
showing how major crime category one
after another so this morning I'm at
Pier 45 where there was that terrible
attack that you just referenced and in
New York City rape is up 15 year over
year so what people want is for their
candidates whether it's the governor the
person running for that position to be
talking about how we understand why
you're upset about this here are my
solutions to fix it we'll have a zero
tolerance for crime we're going to
support our men and women in law
enforcement we're going to fire Rogue
District Attorneys who refuse to enforce
the law we're going to roll back these
pro-criminal laws that they have passed
but you're not getting that leadership
instead they just want the deflection
the distraction to talk about something
else they want us focused on these
issues like crime and the economy they
don't want to see us trying to come up
with some excuse for why there's no
responsibility to deal with any of this
if you don't want to deal with it then
don't run for the position now we have a
question from Gabriel Ortega and NYU
student Gabriel
good evening Congressman Selden my name
is Gabe Ortega I'm from Brooklyn New
York and I'm also a first year college
student here in New York City
in recent years I have seen the city
that I love deteriorate and become a
shell of itself because our elected
leaders do not want to enforce the laws
that keep us safe
what would you do as governor to address
my concerns about Public Safety
the first the first thing that I would
do the first day that I'm in office is
tell them it had district attorney Alvin
Bragg that he's being removed for his
refusal to enforce the law
listen while playing a is for the state
legislature to come to the table and
work with me they're saying that they're
not going to work together with the need
to roll back these pro-criminal laws
like cashless bail so what we're going
to do on day one to force them to the
table is that we are going to declare a
crime emergency here in the state of New
York and we are going to suspend
cashless bail less is more raise the age
the halt act the discovery Law changes
we have to force them to come to the
table you deserve you're a governor to
be doing absolutely everything in their
power to make your life here in New York
City safer on the streets in the Subways
you're not getting that now and I also
am relieved to think about the law
enforcement officer who's going to be
able to go to sleep on January 1st
knowing that once again they have a
governor who has their back
all right
now Congressman
um people always people have heard me
say so many times because I work for
President Reagan that Reagan campaigned
in the Bronx in 1980 he ended his
campaign it was right in the last week
or two ended in the Bronx made several
stops in New York he took his campaign
to all 50 states he went into the belly
of the Beast of liberalism to sell
conservatism now you did that today
which I love in Greenwich Village okay
talk about the belly of the Beast and I
love Greenwich Village but it's really
left-wing well you were met with a
little bit of protest watch
how do you vote against
okay so that was like four people but um
go back to Long Island this is this idea
again that if if you're if you're not a
died in the world Democrat you're not a
real New Yorker remember Kathy hokel
said that uh not so long ago yes what
about that she declared that I'm no
longer a New Yorker because I'm
challenging her she demanded that I get
on a bus and move to Florida
if you want to be the governor you have
to be willing to and want to be the
governor for all New Yorkers but she's
not willing to do that I want to be the
governor for all the workers so why did
you go why was it important why was it
important for you to go to Greenwich
Village because the people there want to
see their leaders showing up yesterday a
woman is jogging and she gets choked and
assaulted and raped and the people who
live in that Community are shocked by
what happened we all should be there we
should all be there talking about our
ideas to make sure that this doesn't
happen again so what we're just talking
about with that last question when I
mentioned that on day one I'll do a
crime emergency those people who are
shouting one of the woman shouts out
there is no crime emergency no actually
there is and people want to see that
leadership from us and they're not
getting it from Kathy hokel they're not
getting it when Hillary Clinton and
Kamala Harris show up there's a reason
why when that rally was going on with
them yesterday with a couple hundred
people there at the same time we had
about 3 000 people up in the cab Capital
Region we have the momentum we have the
energy and losing is not an option we're
getting rid of all these vaccine
mandates so are those going get rid of
it I do not support any covert vaccine
mandate in any way shape or form on
anyone for any purpose health care
workers police all gone every single
person who's been fired should get their
jobs back with back pay love it
[Applause]
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else